Hi, I'm Katherine,
and I like capitalism,
a lot.
But in my 20 years
as a libertarian journalist,
I have started to pick up
that some people aren't as fond
of capitalism as I am.
That's fine, but here's the thing.
I think a lot of the stuff
that you think you hate about capitalism
is actually stuff to hate
about government.
Before we get started kvetching, though,
I want to sing you a little song,
and you've probably heard it before,
so feel free to sing along, if you like.
Don’t worry, I’m not actually
going to sing. It’s fine.
200 years ago, in 1820,
the global rate of absolute poverty --
which is defined, imperfectly,
as living on less than one dollar
and 90 cents a day --
was 84 percent.
That's enormous.
Today, the World Bank
puts that number at nine percent.
Over the same period,
life expectancy went
from less than 30 years to 72,
and there were similarly remarkable gains
in access to food, water,
housing, education
during that period.
That period coincides so neatly
with the rise of global capitalism
that I flatly refuse
to believe it's a coincidence.
I think sometimes, we get so caught up
in talking about what capitalism
could or should be
that we forget what it has been
and what it is.
So I wanted to just take
a minute to do some,
like, greatest hits of capitalism.
They include electric light,
personal mobile phones,
cheap fertilizer, commercial aviation.
And current capitalists
are working on cool stuff
like cryptocurrencies and geoengineering
and plant-based meat.
I also recently learned that there is
a zero-sugar, alcoholic version
of Taco Bell's Baja Blast Mountain Dew.
(Laughter)
And I don't actually know
if that's a point for
or against my argument,
but I did feel like you should know.
(Laughter)
So, amongst all of this miraculous
market activity,
we also have government,
and that means we have two problems.
The first problem
is that governments don't love it
when weird new stuff gets born.
Second problem is that governments
also don't love it
when familiar old stuff dies.
So let's talk about the new stuff first.
The thing about capitalism
is that it is an emergent system.
It's, like all evolutionary mechanisms,
powered by mutations.
And in this case, what the mutations are
are very weird people trying new stuff.
And when we need
really big progress, big new stuff,
that means we need
really, really weird people.
Elon, looking at you, buddy.
I don't know where you are today.
(Laughter)
Prior to the rise of modern capitalism,
it absolutely sucked to be weird.
Best-case scenario -- a new idea ended up
kind of dying on the vine
for lack of opportunities
or resources to go forward.
Worst-case scenario,
trying something heroic and new
could put you at odds
with the powers that be
in times and places
when those powers were absolute.
So imagine you have a great plan
to open up a new trade route
between Europe and Asia
during the Anglo-Dutch Wars.
That is a brilliant way
to get a face full of cannonballs.
I'm not saying that every weirdo
has a brilliant apocalypse-averting idea
that also happens to be
a viable commercial enterprise.
Most new ideas are bad.
There’s a reason people
haven’t done it before.
Just like most mutations
are evolutionary dead ends.
But that's OK, because
high-functioning capitalism
is characterized by a tremendous amount
of corporate failure.
Governments don't actually like it
when familiar old corporations fail.
They prefer to do business
with the taxable, already regulated
devils that they know.
But that's too bad,
because my personal
favorite thing about companies
is that they can die.
When companies die, of course,
that imposes a hardship on customers,
on employees, on communities,
on your 401(k).
My family wasn't allowed to set foot
in a Walmart for a generation,
after Walmart put my granddaddy's
general store out of business,
so I get it.
At the same time, failure is the fate
of nearly every company,
and that is why capitalism works.
Imagine, if you will,
when a company fails,
it releases into the market
labor and resources,
talent that can be better used elsewhere.
Imagine a tree falling in the forest
and rotting and fueling new growth.
Good news, though,
for fans of corporate death like myself:
the original Fortune 500 list, in 1955 --
of the companies on that list,
only 52 are still on the list.
That means 90 percent of those companies
either went under, or merged,
or fell off the list altogether.
And corporate death
does seem to be accelerating.
The life span of a company
on the S and P 500
was 61 years in the late '50s;
today, it's less than 18.
To better understand
this corporate birth-and-death dynamic,
I’m going to tell you
two wildly oversimplified stories.
The first is about General Motors,
and the second is about Facebook.
Now, I didn't pick these companies
because I think they are particularly evil
or even terribly unusual.
They're doing stuff that makes sense
in a system that's a little bit broken.
So let's start by talking
about General Motors.
General Motors is actually
one of the tiny number of companies
from that original
Fortune 500 list in 1955
that's still hanging out near the top.
And starting a car company
is moderately nuts.
Really, at any time.
It's a pretty impressive thing
that they took what was once
a ridiculous luxury
and turned it into an everyday necessity.
But then, government got used to GM,
GM got used to governments.
And by 1981, government is using
the power of eminent domain
to wipe out an entire
working-class neighborhood in Detroit
just because GM
wants to build a factory there.
That coddling continues
through the 2008 financial crisis,
when GM received really quite a massive
bailout from the government.
That's not market failure,
that's government failure.
Market would have stripped GM
for parts a long time ago.
Now let's talk about Facebook.
Same deal, right?
Sort of, wacky people trying something new
just to see if it'll work.
And at first, Facebook was fun, remember?
We got hot dates and we found lost dogs,
and college reunions became
totally obsolete, which was awesome.
(Laughter)
A few people made a lot of money,
and the rest of us
were a little bit better off.
But, flash forward 14 or 15 years,
and Facebook is being called repeatedly
to the congressional carpet
to answer for, actually,
all the sins of big tech.
Mark Zuckerberg, though,
takes a conciliatory stance.
He asks only to be allowed to help write
the regulations that will govern his firm,
and, coincidentally,
those of his competitors.
Here's where it gets
a little complicated, though,
because even as some legislators
are working with Facebook lobbyists
to write rules for the industry,
others have introduced a bill
to break up Facebook
and punish it for its sheer size.
Meanwhile, an informal poll
of the Gen Zers in my life
informs me that Facebook is "cringe."
(Laughter)
TikTok is eating Facebook’s lunch,
and the first-quarter earnings report
of Meta came with a surprise.
The market cap of the firm
had actually dropped
below the level written into that bill
to punish firms for being too big.
So the joke's on Congress.
Facebook is going to end up
avoiding regulation by shrinking,
but unfortunately, it's going to take
its competitors with it.
This is a classic example of politicians
being lagging, not leading, indicators.
We are rich thanks to two centuries
of global capitalism,
but we do still have problems.
As a great sage once observed,
“mo money” may in fact correlate
with “mo problems.”
(Laughter)
The way forward is to figure out
what the public and private sector
can each do best
and help them figure out
how to stay in their lane.
When it comes to government,
I am open to the possibility
that the answer
to what it can do best is ...
nothing.
(Laughter)
But we don't all have to become
anarchists today.
It's clear that liberal
institutions, rule of law,
functioning courts,
private-property rights
have been very powerful
in this project of fostering innovation.
You already know what markets do best.
They let people try stuff,
they send strong signals
when that stuff isn't working,
and they have fueled
an incredible arc of growth
and poverty eradication.
If we are to have optimism
for a radically better world
to continue this path
that capitalism has put us on,
we cannot let governments
collaborate with business
to wreck the engine of the market.
Weirdos trying stuff
and sometimes being allowed to fail at it
are our best hope as a species.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)